[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the section of the show that
we call the bonehead of the week this
week's edition of bonehead of the week
i'm alone this week because gabe is out
there having fun he deserves a lot of he
deserves to have a great uh weekend he's
he's having fun with some friends and
they're they they're they're celebrating
for a wedding that's upcoming
he worked really hard on all the
graphics for the hearing and for the
show he he does a lot of hard work that
that you get to see but you don't get to
see
the sausage being made he works really
hard here so we appreciate gabe so go
show gabe some love over on twitter go
follow him i am gabe sanchez give him
some heart some likes on fire and tell
him you missed him for the bonehead of
the week
but here's our contestants this week we
have kevin mccarthy steve scalise
and matt getz
oh what a cast of characters it usually
ends up being a bunch of white dudes on
these on these tiles that gave me gabe
made these tiles
even on his trip this weekend he's still
he's still working
but here is our
contestants for bonehead of the week and
you asked tony why
why oh why oh why oh why
are these the boneheads of the week well
kevin mccarthy was actually on the
bonehead of the week for a separate
reason
um and if i can pull if i'm gonna pull
it up here now again bear with me here
because normally what happens
is i get i get gabe to talk
um while i'm looking up things
and today that's just
it's just not what's gonna happen so you
have to bear with me for a minute but
we're gonna get through this you
remember the the video of kevin mccarthy
pointing and yelling on the house floor
um the other day yesterday the day
before i don't remember
i don't remember
um
but here here he is on
then this is an oan clip and i don't
know if oan's the only one that would
play this [ __ ]
but here he is on oan
um and he's in his press conference but
listen to who he blames
the insurrection on this is [ __ ] just
boneheaded at its best let's listen you
said both publicly and privately after
january 6th that you thought trump for
some responsibility for the attack do
you still feel like he was in any way
responsible for justice i've answered
that many times i thought everybody in
the country beared some responsibility
based upon what has been going on the
riots on the streets the others
you said both publicly and privately
after everyone in america is responsible
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
that's literally what this guy's gonna
say
is that everyone in america is
responsible well that's enough for b to
be on the bonehead of the week for me
really honestly now that's not the
that's not the actual reason why
we put him on bonehead of the week um
but i think that's enough and i think
that's why uh you're gonna see today
kevin mccarthy is our winner here on
bone of the week
but that that is enough for me
now here's here's the other here's the
other thing about kevin mccarthy is
there was a video um that i'm going to
show here in a bit about kevin mccarthy
um and
now that midas touch had uh posted a
clip of this so we're gonna watch here
later why i think he actually won the
bonehead of the week poll why you voted
for him um so we'll we'll play that here
in just a bit but let's go back to let's
go back to our other winners matt gatz
and steve scalise matt gatz
the reason why we put him on the
bonehead of the week and we played it
yesterday because we kind of we kind of
let you guys make the sausage yesterday
for this bone end of the week matt gads
is on here for the [ __ ] that he said
about jamie raskin of course
you know all these seditionists matt
gatz marjorie taylor greene
lauren bobert
kevin mccarthy the list goes on and on
and on here um are absolutely freaking
out about what's gonna be said
in the select hearing
they're terrified of it absolutely
terrified of it so much so that these
boneheads are saying crazy ass [ __ ] on
them on the floor of the house
i mean here they are here here here's
hoof foot green
sickle fanting
sycophanting
listen
and why their due process rights are
being so fragrantly
and horrifically violated
and why their due process right she's
talking about the people who you seen in
the video just minutes ago
just minutes ago you've seen these
people in these videos
absolutely
tearing apart
of course of course they're getting due
process that's why they're sitting in
detention dummy
is because there's evidence against them
and they're being charged with crimes
it's not [ __ ] rocket science it
really is not hard to understand why
these people are sitting in detention
it it really is
[ __ ] just
looney tunes that we have to sit and
listen to this nonsense and i want to
play another clip of matt gatt's
favorite person because that's in the
clip of
matt gatz talking about jamie raskin's
son committing suicide he's on marjorie
taylor green's show
it's what's happening
and the gross thing about the whole deal
is they're sitting there
yucking it up about jamie raskin
shouldn't be in congress because his
child had committed suicide just vile
gross [ __ ]
and then she goes on the floor of the
house to say this and most of all i want
to finish with this
there is something terrible happening in
this process and it's called defamation
of character
the president the 45th president of the
united states character is being defamed
and all of his staff and his family and
all republicans
everyone's reputation is being defamed
as lies are being told about all of us
and president trump
just for politics and it makes all of us
what the [ __ ] does that mean
think about our mindset here she's
saying she's saying what is happening is
defamation
now this is
of trump and his family
now rather she knew that ivanka trump
was gonna her testimony was gonna be
[ __ ] played last night
or not
i don't know i don't know if she knew
that or not i don't know if she knew
what ivanka trump said in her testimony
but it's under oath you [ __ ] dummy
you're a [ __ ] idiot marjorie taylor
green if you think that ivanka trump
went
and said yes i agree with bill barr when
he says that the big lie is a bunch of
[ __ ]
that the big lie that donald trump told
and that rudy giuliani sydney powell
mike lindell steve bannon and the likes
perpetuated to create a violent
insurrection
on the capitol on the day of january 6.
if you think that her going under oath
and giving her opinion about the big lie
that it's all a bunch of horse [ __ ] is
defamation you are a dumb [ __ ]
of course marjorie taylor green is that
makes me sick it absolutely disgusts me
if we're supposed to represent the
american people and we're supposed to do
a good job and and uphold this place
with honor
uh here here's marjorie taylor green
this is [ __ ] laughable this is
[ __ ] hilarious this is why you can't
parry these p parody these people hardly
you can't make satire of this how can
you make satire this here's margaret
taylor green talking about honor are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] and good for the
people we serve then we should be
truthful
but what's about to happen tonight is
not going to be truthful it's going to
be a political narrative and it's all
for politics and it is sickening yeah
okay
it is all for politics dummy and i said
tonight tonight is gonna be good folks
don't miss the coverage
because it's the truth it is all for
politics
yeah exactly
it's exactly all for politics and it
should be
we should play politics with this folks
that's what the whole [ __ ] january 6
select committee is for
benny
thompson said it in the beginning that
they wanted this
they
wanted a political [ __ ] body they
wanted a political investigation the
republicans had a chance for a
non-partisan non-bias
to congress
9 11 style commission and they said no
and the reason why they said no is
because they wanted to play politics
with january 6 and the results of the
evidence of january 6 they wanted to
play politics they felt like that was
probably the only survival mechanism
that they had was to play politics
so yeah it is politics and we should
play politics
and here's matt gatz in this video of
him i'm not going to play the whole
thing because it's [ __ ] gross it's
really [ __ ] gross these two [ __ ]
sick sons of [ __ ] sitting here
talking about jamie raskin's child
committing suicide and somehow that
should impede him on doing his job you
you dirty vile sick gross [ __ ]
what i worry about with raskin in all
seriousness you know um in all
seriousness you [ __ ] you are not a
[ __ ] serious person and no one takes
off seriously associate a lot mr venmo
that trauma
[ __ ] [ __ ] naturally or or even
rationally associate maybe so and what i
maybe so i'm not even i'm i'm done i'm
done but i'm not even gonna go go
forward anymore that [ __ ] garbage
[ __ ] them
pieces of [ __ ] absolute trash
trash they are
but what are you going to do
uh let's see let's let's move on who
else we get oh steve scalise
steve scalise
you watched him uh
talk about how
oh
oh
airplanes banned we we we didn't ban
airplane maybe we should ban airplanes
after nine uh maybe we we should
regulate
what a [ __ ] idiot you guys remember
this clip do you remember this
of steve scalise let me see if i can
find it here again normally yeah my
co-host gabe sanchez is talking while
i'm looking here it is looking for clips
actually gabe had a tweet here about it
let's let's pull up gabe's tweet here he
said with a
uh it was a
con
conversation about connecting the dots
how we can try to figure out if there's
signs we can see to stop the next attack
from happening and he's talking about
gun violence right and he's talking
about he's trying to compare it to the
911 attack steve scalise is a victim of
gun violence and he still runs through
the point like he runs straight through
it here now let's watch here let's pull
this up here um here he is talking about
banning airplanes after 9 11. he doesn't
get it problems that were creating those
attacks
and airplanes were used that day
as the weapon to kill thousands of
people and to inflict terror on our
country okay number one and we mentioned
this the other day number one
you [ __ ] idiot
airplanes like airplane manufacturers
don't [ __ ] build airplanes to kill
people
okay number one never [ __ ] won
scalise you dumb son of a [ __ ] have you
ever went to a baseball field and just
had airplanes shot at you steve scalise
you stupid bastard this is a [ __ ] guy
who is a victim of gun violence the son
of a [ __ ] almost died
and he's still in the pocket of the nra
the nra paid him to come out and say
this [ __ ] into a microphone i said it
the nra paid this [ __ ] to say
this vile [ __ ]
steve scalise did not have airplanes
hurdle that his hurdle let him in a
baseball field
that's not what happened
he was shot by a gun but listen to what
he says about regulating airplanes
even though airplanes aren't designed to
kill people they're actually designed to
keep people safe like they actually
build airplanes engineer airplanes they
have federal regulations on airplanes
that we
we put in place we the people vote for
elected officials who make sure that the
[ __ ] airplanes that we ride on
are [ __ ] regulated so they're safe
for humans and don't kill us
you stupid [ __ ]
there wasn't a conversation about
banning airplanes there was a
conversation about connecting the dots
how can we try to figure out
if there are signs we can see to stop
the next attack from happening
oh my god yeah there is a conversation
about it yep exactly
no one no one is saying there's not one
[ __ ] public official that i can find
and i don't even know that there's one
person that you would you would talk to
in this country that would believe that
gun manufacturers are going to stop
manufacturing guns
right
i don't i and we're going to ban all
guns i don't think there's one person
that believe there may be some people
that want to do that but they pray even
the people who want to do that probably
believe that that won't happen
in our country there's i mean it's hard
to imagine that there would be no guns
there's there's more guns and there are
people right now so it's hard to believe
that that would ever be a
a future that would come to fruition and
anyone even people who want that
probably wouldn't believe it if you told
them that
because the evidence is stacked against
you
but he says
we we tried to figure out a way to make
sure that this wouldn't happen again
yeah you dumb [ __ ]
yeah we put all kinds of regulations in
place to make sure that a person can't
use a [ __ ] plane to kill thousands of
people
think about that because they always
blame it on the person it's not the gun
it's the person well if it's not the
plane and it's the person we sure as
hell put a hell of a lot of regulations
to make sure we know who the [ __ ] is on
an airplane so that they can't use it as
a weapon to kill a bunch of innocent
people you dumb son of a [ __ ]
pluck your head out of your ass steve
scalise and understand what you're
saying what you're saying here you're
running straight through the point
is yes most americans realize that we're
not going to be able to [ __ ] stop the
gun manufacturers from manufacturing
guns and we won't be able to ban all
firearms
most americans probably 99.9
would agree with that fact whether you
like it or not
i mean [ __ ] we pretty much
we we pretty much did away with smoking
in this country but we didn't ban the
manufacturers from from from [ __ ]
getting cigarettes did we no or from
manufacturing cigarettes did we know and
cigarettes killed hundreds of thousands
of people
we just made it to where they couldn't
advertise in certain ways they couldn't
attract certain audiences you know like
young children to start smoking or 18
year old crazy ass 18 year olds to go
buy guns on a credit card to go
slaughter 19 children at a school
this is really [ __ ] dumb stupid [ __ ]
that he is talking about here because
he's actually making the argument this
is more of this projection-ass [ __ ]
let's listen
and some people might have thought that
wasn't possible
and yet because congress came together
and focused on the root cause of the
problem thank god we have been able to
stop other attacks on our homeland and
there and ran more into the point by
admitting that yes you got to get to the
root of the problem which the problem
that we're talking about here steve
scalise is the [ __ ] gun it's the gun
it's the gun it's the gun you dumb sons
of [ __ ]
it is the gun
so thank you to our co-host gabe sanchez
for posting that video so i had it up
and ready
we also have some dishonorable mention
in alphacuts you guys know
you guys know here on
the bonehead of the week we always have
a problem here's the problem that we
have with bone of the week we fill in
the bone of the week these three people
and then at the last minute there
emerges more
boneheads
more boneheads appear
and
there was a lot of boneheads there was
jack del rio this week there was tucker
carlson there was marjorie taylor green
there was marco rubio
but the alpha guy of the week went to
mr sean hannity and i believe the reason
why we agreed to have sean hannity as
the alpha cuck of the week is because of
us of
marco rubio on his show but actually you
know what uh
let's see here let's go back here
uh i think i have gabe sanchez holy moly
you actually did join me for bonehead of
the week i joined you i told you i'd be
here i'm you know i had a client we're
gonna tell you that you're not in some
bunker somewhere are you did you no no
did you flee to some mountain top away
from i had to for my own safety i had to
go to uh undisclosed location are you
camping or what the hell is going on out
there
look i can't give you details just know
that i'm safe i
am uh
just want to let everyone know you know
thank you so much for for
tuning in last night i i can't tell you
how grateful tony and i am for the
people who who stayed through and
watched
the defending of democracy happen um and
a big thank you to the myself brothers
and minus touch and all of our our
pundits that came on and gave their gave
their expertise and and what they had to
say about
the hearings and everything that
happened that had to happen um you know
super grateful and thankful for everyone
that listened that that came in
that chatted uh thank you thank you so
much uh but yeah i figured i would i
would i would jump in during bonehead of
the week i mean i can't not you know
that's i can't break that can't break
the uh
the the uh
the thing that we have going on here in
front i'm blanking on what i'm trying to
say but i know well here's the thing
here i'm a higher altitude right well
that that the scenery is much better
there than in than in your grandma's
basement yeah i don't know if people
know this but that that room that gave
look at that look at that look at the
view here here let me put it on the full
screen look at this
look at this view that gabe sanchez is
oh my god
oh my god everyone be jealous of of gabe
sanchez here on the bonehead
we should have made we we should have
made gabe the bonehead of the week
because he didn't invite us all to come
where he's at um gabe i want to tell you
real quick uh why we have you because i
don't know how long we have you but i
want to thank you you were thanking
everyone else but you did you did such a
great job with all the
all the design all the effort that you
put in there's so much stuff in the
background that no one saw with all the
spreadsheets and all the documents that
we created to to make sure that the show
went off um all the links that we had
all all the chats that we had going on
um during the last several weeks to get
this production off the ground and you
did a great job and i i don't i don't
know if people know this but you were
kind of at a bachelor party last night
and uh you know they didn't really see
that the the strippers in the background
but you know
we we kind of we kind of maybe you know
maybe next time we'll get a yeah
in the background i mean i was i was
tuckered away in a corner and everyone
else was outside kind of you know having
beers and drinking meanwhile yeah yeah i
was like gotta stay focused gotta watch
what's going on here you know um so i'm
super grateful that we were able to to
to pull that off what we did um
and again so thankful for everyone who
came in and
chatted with us and shared what we were
doing in the hearing so i'm
i'm uh i'm super excited for monday you
know we got a second hearing that'll
happen during the morning during our
normally uh scheduled show
so i'm very pumped about that one yeah
you're going to be up early in the
morning for that one
yeah yeah yeah really very early
yeah
still it's still i mean it's our normal
it's our normal time isn't it well i
mean it's it's
it starts a couple hours earlier than we
start and then it's going to continue on
into our show right so i'm not sure
exactly how we're going to do it we'll
figure that out probably on the flight
speaking on the fly you were even
creating art yesterday while the hearing
was happened you were you were you were
you were having a nice beer and
trying to get the graphics
um for a couple things that we didn't
expect
right yeah i didn't you know we
did not have the stuff ready for uh for
nick the documentary filmmaker and also
caroline edwards the uh capitol police
officer but we got it and we had their
had their name plates ready to go so
that everyone knew who was actually
giving their witness testimony
um
it's seven my time yeah seven your time
man mj's pointing out that yeah mj says
no at seven am your time sorry gabe
guess i'm getting up earlier than that
yeah well it happens it happens
early early to rise
yeah early to you know just got rise and
grind but this is what we do but you
know tony this is it this is it and we
are in i was just going through uh sean
hannity can you stick around real quick
uh because i want to show this video
yeah uh just just just uh just a couple
seconds here i want to show this video
marco rubio and i want to get your
reaction uh to what he says about the
production since we're talking about
production anyways let's listen to this
well if this was a real congressional
hearing and not a kangaroo court and not
a circus and not a made for tv
production and an infomercial for their
political purposes those are the
questions they would be asking that's
exactly what they would be asking it
would be a review of why didn't capitol
police why didn't the sergeant-at-arms
take advantage of these resources that
were available that's what you would be
focused on but they're not going to be
focused on that this is a you know i
mean they moved this thing to prime time
they hired a producer to put it on this
is not a fact-finding mission this is a
two-hour free documentary sponsored by
virtually every major network in america
except for this one that's willing to
give it airtime the only good thing
about it is most americans aren't going
to watch this garbage they i mean people
already know what happens so yesterday
so yesterday oh last night we seen that
that the producer was just to make sure
it all went off right just like we were
doing last night with our production
with all the guests that we had for the
commentary we were just making sure that
everything worked and everyone was there
the mics were working the film was was
up when it needed to be up then i made a
few mistakes you noticed them some
didn't but you noticed them because you
pay attention to the details but sean
hannity last night apparently did not
even go to commercial is what i'm
hearing he didn't even go to commercial
because he didn't want to lose his
audience to people who might go hear the
truth and marco rubio here
he could have been one of our boneheads
and certainly the alpha cuck or the dm
but he he talks about the production but
i find it funny that he's on the show
right he's on sean hannity's show and
last night during the hearing like he's
like oh this is all a documentary it's
all made up it's all blue [ __ ] no one's
gonna watch this trash sean hannity was
a key piece of evidence
in the [ __ ] hearing where they talk
about him and kaylee mack and amy
talking about how do we convince donald
trump just to go away like
it's it's hilarious it is
it is hilarious i mean we had already
you know and the last thing i'll say
before i go is we had already seen liz
cheney read out the text messages from
those fox news correspondents to mark
meadows and now she's like yeah i've got
thousands here that i can even do and
let's play one from sean hannity to
kaylee mcinney and really show how even
more people inside the administration
were having communication with people
who were the the correspondents at fox
seems weird
that they should have that type of uh
kind of direct line or insight or or say
or influence on how it's handled but
i think it's funny by the fact that
that sean hannity again you know he
didn't want to lose anyone and we joked
about it like what would happen if he
was playing if they ever even played the
hearing right and it would have happened
it would have been sean hannity hearing
his name and seeing the text messages
the literal receipts put on screen and
then like oh let's go to commercial that
would have been the only time he would
want to go to commercial right and here
here it is here it is he says in the
text message to caleb magna the number
one thing to try to stop no more crazy
people he says is no more stolen
election talk in other words he's
admitting he's admitting gabe that it's
all [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
and and marco rubio who says it's all a
sham and a fake in a kangaroo court
i highly doubt that any of the
depositions they played last night from
people like ivanka trump bill barr
miller like these are people who are
under oath and have to give testimony or
their death
so i wouldn't say that it's all false
because it's 100 percent true unless of
course those people want to be uh
you know caught in a lie right yeah they
would commit perjury they can make
virtues
so anyway i just wanted to come on here
and say get back get get back to uh
setting up your campsite for your
camping up there so that you can stay
away from all all the trouble that
you've caused in the last few weeks with
your production and thank you again for
all the production
that you put in for the hearing and
we'll see you soon my friend don't don't
have too much fun this i mean have fun
just yeah well you know what have a lot
of fun i'll be ready to go have my
sunday night sleep to get early as as i
was just pointing out it's
my time yeah well and don't do any don't
do anything that donald trump would do
well you know i do a lot of stuff that
donald trump senior donald trump jr
would do do what don jr would do this
weekend gabe do it thanks a lot my
friend you have a good one we'll talk to
you soon thank you very much
holy moly we had gabe sanchez join us
from the mountaintop
up all the way from the mountaintop
thank you gabe for joining us i was
hoping he could cut in and have a good
view from where he was that he sent me a
couple pictures earlier and i was hoping
to cut in here's these text messages
that we were talking about earlier from
kaylee mcinanny and sean hannity because
you know he's our alpha cuck
of the week
um i i want to point out a few more
things here and there the reason why is
because kayla kaylee mcaney's response
now remember gailey magnani is the one
who was
lying out in the public as the press
secretary when he said no more crazy
people to her she said yes a hundred
percent it's hard to see here but yes a
hundred percent she says and then he
says no more election talk or no more
stolen election doc she says i love that
thank you this is our playbook
now
it's not the playbook
to to
to to win the election right
she's not saying here
um this is the playbook to win the
election and steal the election and have
a an insurrection that's that's the
playbook that happened on january 6th
this is after january 6.
this is when he went out on the lawn and
said oh i love you people you people are
so nice
and so great and we love you but go home
remember the video and i think we're
going to have a few different versions
of that video in these hearings but this
is after that when this guy was delusion
when they were talking about the 25th
amendment
i mean even in these texts look look
here look in these texts it says
it says
yes impeachment in 27th amendment or
25th amendment is real
in other words yes people are talking
about 25th in him yes we need to get him
to believe that people are talking about
2015
his ass
that is the thing that we need to do to
convince him to shut the [ __ ] up and go
away because that's what they were
trying to do because they knew it was
all lie they knew it was all [ __ ]
they knew had gone too far
and that they did not want him [ __ ]
touching anything they didn't want him
to be alone with government
he would grab it by the [ __ ] is what
they were scared of
so that's why sean hannity
he's our alpha cuck because not only was
he cucking for trump but then he was he
was cucking to get him to shut up and
then last night he couldn't even air it
wouldn't even aaron what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
speaking of [ __ ] uh you heard last
night also that a representative scott
perry
scott perry was one of the
representatives that was seeking a
pardon apparently um liz cheney talks
about it
uh in the in the hearing um let me see
if i can pull the video up where she
talks about scott perry and the members
of congress and i think this is very
significant
and the reason why i believe this is so
significant is because she says that
they were lined up
lined up
to for pardons like this this is this is
some [ __ ] that needs to be outed and i
said it earlier on in the episode i
think that whatever that list is of
people who are seeking pardons
i believe
i believe that that list of people who
are seeking pardons
is the expulsion list right i mean why
would you seek a pardon him
if not to if not
if not to circumvent any crimes you've
already committed that you know you've
committed
and here's liz cheney last night talking
about scott
perry and trying to get pardons
as you will see
representative perry contacted the white
house in the weeks after january 6th to
seek a presidential pardon
multiple other republican congressmen
also sought presidential pardons for
their roles in attempting to overturn
the 2020 election
as you will see
representative perry contacted the white
house in the weeks after january 6
to seek a presidential pardon
yep yep yep yep play it over and over
and over and over again folks
do not let up on this this is super
important that we
we definitely hear that over and over
again and that's why scott perry and
maybe we should have like an you know
whole list of dishonorable mention and
maybe just maybe in these hearings we
will find out that list of dishonorable
mentions
that will make their way
um to
evidence inside the committee
about
who was the members of congress that
were seeking pardons that's what i want
to know
not just scott perry here
but the other members of congress so
that's why he was our dishonorable
mention this week but i want to go boy i
want to go to the winner
the winner is kevin mccarthy
for bonehead of the week
um not just for his little tirade that
he had on the floor the other day losing
his [ __ ] mind
but more about the evidence that they
provided last night and liz chang liz
janey darth vader jr you guys know that
i'm i'm not a fan
necessarily
of liz cheney what i mean by that is i
actually don't think she's this
this person who is
who is
100 for democracy and here's why she's
not voting she didn't vote for voting
rights she doesn't want women to have
bodily autonomy in this country she's
not for your liberty
but the enemy of your enemy sometimes
can be your friend and right now liz
cheney's goal is to destroy trumpism and
to destroy the big line because i
believe that liz cheney knows deep down
inside her black heart her cold black
heart if she has a heart
i don't know maybe her father gave her
what was remaining of his
inside her cold black heart i don't know
maybe just maybe
liz cheney knows
that if trumpism survives in her party
her party is done
and she wants to be the leader of her
party she wants to regain her party the
party of darth vader of dick cheney her
father
because she is darth vader jr but last
night boy
let me tell you something uh and texas
paul said it last night
on the the
the remainder
uh the after show of the commentary of
the hearing texas paul said that she was
going to napalm kevin mccarthy and here
is a preview of how she absolutely
destroys him you will hear that leaders
on capitol hill begged the president for
help
including republican leader mccarthy who
was quote scared who was quote
scared
no [ __ ] to give with liz cheney on
kevin mccarthy she doesn't she has no
[ __ ] sympathy for that son of a [ __ ]
who at first was scared and who said yes
we need to stop this [ __ ] he even went
on air
on tv
live saying we need to stop this [ __ ]
that he had contacted the president to
stop this [ __ ] and liz cheney saying
he's scared and he turned even on her
when she said the truth
and called multiple members of president
trump's family after he could not
persuade the president himself
not only did president trump refuse to
tell the mob to leave the capitol
he placed no call to any element of the
united states government to instruct
that the capital be defended
he did not call his secretary of defense
on january 6. he did not talk to his
attorney general he did not talk to the
department of homeland security
president trump gave no order to deploy
the national guard that day
so there you have it there is the reason
why kevin mccarthy is the bonehead of
the week
so everybody let's give
oh kevin mccarthy his due you voted for
him we break it down
and let's give old kevin mccarthy his
due here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
kevin mccarthy the bone end of
the week
thanks for joining us for bonehead of
the week i appreciate it and i'm glad
that gabe sanchez
did not break the streak and he joined
us for bonehead of the week again go
give him some love go go follow gabe on
twitter at i am gabe sanchez talk about
give him give him some love about the
campsite that he's got but follow us at
tony michael's pod where you can vote
for bone end of the week
every single week on thursday usually
thursday evening you can also vote on
youtube so don't forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel
at tonymichaelspod
follow us on youtube and twitter and
vote every single week for bonehead of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]